hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to there's
a theory going around the comic book
heroes are the great modern myths in the
same way that Hercules our Perseus were
the great Greek myths well if that's
true then Captain America must be do
chicest because he sure doesn't hold up
now I'm not talking about the comic
books themselves I'd never really read
those I'm solely going by the low-budget
action film that actually came out in
1990 under the same name Captain America
never heard of it there's a reason
ridiculously stupid and embarrassingly
over-the-top Captain America was among
one of the cheesiest comic-book movies
ever made and knowing that she's a comic
books already are that's pretty bad so
strap on your Devil Horde eagle wings
and let's take a look at Captain America
so the credits roll is we start off this
classic American story about a classic
American superhero in the classic
American heartland of Italy unusual
start
what the Mario Puzo varenka's come on
where's the action so we young child
prodigies taken away from his family and
used as a guinea pig in an evil
experiment what does the experiment do a
kind of alkali Savannah f you see say
Bethany's spy they kind the Harryhausen
effect the scientists running the
experiment doesn't want to harm a child
and thus she escapes this evil heavily
armed military base by just jumping out
the window
well that was unrealistically simple we
then cut to seven years later yet thanks
we can do the math we see an injured
soldier named Steve Rogers who's leaving
his home to partake in a similar
experiment that could heal his leg and
make him even stronger everyone comes to
say goodbye except for his girlfriend
Bernie I'm sorry it's just
it's just I love you that's why I've
been come to send you off can't imagine
not knowing what you're doing
so it appears that there's is a romance
that will always last about 20 seconds
I'm serious they share the screen for
just 20 seconds before he leaves
I feel more attached to my toothbrush in
that amount of time cell anyway they
take him to a secret base located just
under in every day of restaurant how's
the pot roast today Roz about as good as
investor day hmm yeah looks like the
usual service at Denny's so they go
downstairs to the secret laboratory
where they're trying to create the
perfect American superhero and ultimate
Grand Slam breakfast they may not be
Superman but it'll be a living symbol of
what this country stands well I agree
with the first part
that was just to see if it was on here's
the real deal
oh wait the camera wasn't recording
let's try again Thank You Mandy
so the experiment works Steve's leg is
cured and he seems more powerful than
ever before
down lookers wish to congratulate the
scientists a remarkable work dr.
casselli
congratulations Oh what was that
Wow
that was the most over-the-top way to
kill somebody I give you props guy but
it's mighty silly I mean it's just so
sporadic you could call off the psych
Hitler you go in to shake someone's hand
it's like psych you think he does that
everywhere like at weddings a toast to
the bride and groom on this the happiest
day of their high oh how about bar
mitzvahs you think he does it there
Jimmy now that you're officially a man
let us celebrate with this most sacred
of Jewish tradition or good god what if
he was a kindergarten teacher the itsy
bitsy spider went up the water spout
down came the rain so the scientist is
killed as Steve is shot and put in the
hospital Colonel let young man's lucky
do it survive the surgery I'm all level
with you doctor
I am Matt Dillon's brother what's at
stake here is the lives of thousands of
innocent people but it turns out all his
wounds are healed as he's ready to leap
into action and get revenge
oh you can't do that Bumi you get to
toss them into the outfit I mean have
you seen it
there's carwash clowns that look more
dignified than that if you don't give
some buildup or explanation nobody's got
to take it seriously turn the Lewis sir
there's something nobody's talked about
when do I get some fresh troops in my
battalion dr. casselli had all the
details to the process in her head
besides you got that crazy fireproof
uniform dr. casselli made up for you she
didn't know much about camouflage but
she sure did love the red when she
thought dressing you up like a human
bullseye would do much better and
throwing the enemy off so after that
extremely weak explanation about the
costume they toss him out of the plane
to go hunt some Nazis
I hope fine looks silly enough
but they invade extra so after he
defeats the Nazis with his flying saucer
sled he makes it to their main
headquarters refines the child mails
experimented on at the beginning of the
film who is now transformed into Freddy
Krueger's wax sculpture back actually
he's known as Red Skull who is saving
much more powerful than the mighty camp
Captain America kind of sucks painting
him he's like a child so after getting
his blue Mads kick they strap into a
missile and plan to launch him towards
the White House where is the big bomb
boy
White House a present for President
Roosevelt Oh Captain America get out of
this one will he turn the White House
into rubble or will he escape to get his
American ass beaten what's more tune in
next time which is right now do can
travel cheaply as watch bastard
I'd give my right hand to get my right
hand back yeah thanks movie I never will
figure that out so in that place that's
apparently hard to identify a young boy
named Tom Kimble dreams about the
possibilities of Washington how
expensive sleep mom we're in Washington
DC when I grew up I'll be President I
want to invade countries that will get a
bj in the Oval Office and not be able to
pass a questionable health care bill
president
so because the kid is just so gosh darn
excited he sneaks out in the middle of
the night to take pictures of the White
House Wow what a dork well that's just
silly
Captain America actually kicks the
rocket over the White House just missing
when did this turn to a Debbie dump her
too
so the rocket somehow lands in Alaska
without exploding and leaves Captain
America in the snow
our hero ladies and gentlemen our hero
just when you're hoping he'll disappear
from the movie altogether he sort of
does literally decades go by without any
mention of the guy I guess the movie
just decided to give up so we get all
the way to the 90s where that Tom
Kimball boy throws up and actually does
become president of the United States a
white guy is president it's gonna
believe that this day we don't take he
needs up with a guy named general
Fleming plane
unlike the father from a Christmas story
you just simply can't expect us to cut
back on our solid waste 90% in six
months we had to be as frie Gigli as
possible
we then come to the League of
Extraordinary accents for all sorts of
evildoers plan evil things it turns out
the general is among them as well you're
gonna see everything that you've worked
for and plan for for the last 30 years
go right down the crapper assassination
used were the trouble no who's this guy
this is a new villain or something wait
a minute
that's Red Skull what happened to him
did he just magically grow its skin back
there's plastic surgery and then there's
fuckin miracles guys I mean isn't the
whole reason they called him Red Skull
because oh I don't know he had a friggin
Red Skull okay whatever after Red Skull
becomes numbskull they discuss their
diabolical plans to kidnap the president
and brainwash him to do their evil grace
I am more humble businessmen
with doubles in science before you make
your decision say wasn't there a Captain
America in this movie yeah I know
because it changed so much over the
decades will you lay off the
descriptions
so they find Captain America years later
literally frozen in a block of ice as
they just thaw him out in their tents
and he just walks off like nothing
happened that's pretty weak no wait did
that just happen
I can't believe we just thought out a
basketball mascot so the president hears
about this and rather than oh I don't
know called a Secret Service or
something he calls his childhood friend
played by Ned Beatty like he's 8 years
old again would you sure it's not some
kind of crazy hoax can you spare me the
conspiracy theory just this once I love
your childish ravings I'm talking about
a superhero that was tracked to a
missile and thousand a nice red skull
just fuck you movie do you really think
we can't figure out where this is I mean
seriously why don't you just have a
subtitle under everything and background
on everyone on his security staff
consider it done mr. census so as I was
saying red skull discovered about
Captain America - and the census finest
hot chicks to track him down
but thankfully the president is quick to
act as he sends one pudgy middle-aged
journalist to handle the situation am I
in the circus
so Captain America escapes the evil
supermodels on dirt bikes because he
heroically cowards into a pickup truck
being driven by Ned Beatty I honestly
could not make this up if I tried this
red skull guy was closely involved in
the murders of Robert Kennedy John
Kennedy Martin Luther King okay okay
stop stop stop
you're seriously going to bring up the
assassination of Martin Luther King jr.
in a movie that has this thing in it why
do I get the feeling that's not gonna
mesh would you pull the car over please
I think I'm gonna be sick so Captain
America pretends to be carsick and I'm
not kidding here steals the car away
this guy's an asshole when he's not
getting his useless butt kicked he's
either hiding under something or running
away
captain douchebag so it goes back to his
old home only to find his girlfriend of
two sentences is married and has an
identical twin daughter and yes she's
played by the same actress everyone kept
saying that missing in action was just
another way of savings blown to
smithereens but I never believed them
not for one second that's why I got
married and ugly and and look at you you
ugly
a chance I don't care if you look like a
female Jon Voight it just turns me on
more but Red Skull sends out more
fashion models to hunt him down that
killer look at this it looks like
recover a vote so they break into the
house you Kris Kristofferson and killed
dear old birdie poisoned another oh I
can't stand to watch myself die we also
find out that while this was going on
the president was in fact kidnapped the
President of the United States was
abducted from his hotel in Rome boy our
armed forces really kind of suck dumping
they created me on action hero who can't
fight I let the roar of a free nation
get abducted without a cutscenes these
guys couldn't have beat Cobra so through
a series of driving snooping and yes
more heroic hiding even the daughter
find a need to travel to Rome in order
to find an evil Red Skull could you pull
over for a minute I think I'm gonna be
sick
okay oh god not again you dickweed what
are you doing I can't take it into
danger Captain America so we see Steve
trying to talk to some of the local
people but doesn't manage to get far
cause the valet thing um speaking I I
was wondering I like that do you speak
English
no well I don't just do speak Bongiorno
the daughter somehow manages to follow
his car on point and proceeds to help
them out with her Italian which makes
the previous scene entirely pointless so
they find an old tape recorder that has
the recording of red skulls kidnapping
as a child
Casa but they're then approached by red
skulls hot chicks who try to kill him
again
pretty slow on those gums ladies I mean
not moving like you're doing a yoga move
just wake it out so if are taking a
pretty standard chasing with no real
surprises
hi a giant car he's about to run you
over
I mean what are you kids won damages all
wrong stupids
I love this he pushes the daughter out
of the way of the fight so he can get
hit with a bike with some reason I
thought it was a superhero or something
so he grabs the bike of his own beat off
into the sunset and although I mean
really are you even surprised no my song
well gee it's not like we can just keep
looking for 10 more seconds let's go
ladies so they finally find the location
of the President as they sneak into
their hideout to Satan this looks like a
job for flamboyance so the president
escapes but is cornered by the bad guys
he's brilliant way out killing itself
hey after being in this movie I don't
blame you but luckily Captain America
just happened to be climbing up the wall
at the time wait on the north shore
there's some caves there at the base of
the cliff goodbye I'll come and get you
when we get out are you kidding I'm not
bailing out on Captain America good you
can probably kick more ass than he can
so he confronts Red Skull as we get some
flips gigs punches the president oughta
send his multicolored pizza pan as he
escapes to the roof
mr. president thanks Mentos the
freshmaker so Red Skull goes to arm
another bomb which is in a piano yeah
whatever
as Captain America does what he's best
at hiding like a pussy but the daughter
plays the recording of his kidnapping to
distract him as Captain America gets out
his wonderful spirit knocks him off the
cliff
all right just decapitated a hot chick I
am a great American Hero
so the president calls in his Scottish
ninja army men as Captain America hugs
his dear daughter and it's one less
speech to the audience in Rome today 116
nations agreed to an environmental
protection treaty in a brief statement
after the signing okay if you start
rolling the credits over the dialogue we
kind of figure is not in for fight
though
most important plot points happened
before the movie is over so yeah just
going by this movie alone it appears
that Captain America would be the lamest
superhero ever I mean just look at the
highlights on the back of the box it's
Captain America getting beaten up by Red
Skull and being strapped to the bomb
these are the heroic highlights kids oh
I also like this where it says that
Captain America is a high-flying
adventure for children of all ages as
long as you're over the age of 13 this
is crap plain and simple
it's a wimpy superhero it's a boring
story and the production value looks
like it was more out of the seventies
that was the 90s but to be fair this is
a very tough superhero to pull off I
mean what guy could honestly look the
least bit intimidating in that
ridiculous outfit Chuck Norris remember
it so you don't hatch
Oh